-♪ Hey, hey ♪
♪ Hey, robot ♪
-Ricky! Thank you so much
for doing this.
I appreciate it.
With this one,
I think you'll like it.
It's called "Hey, Robot," okay?
-Right.
-I'm going to pull
a word out of this jar,
and then, what you're going to
have to do is --
I'm going to press the button,
and then you talk to,
in this case, Alexa, and you
can't say the word on the note,
but you have to try
to get the robot
to say the word on the note.
-Okay.
-Alright, ready?
This is the word.
-Okay.
-You have to get her
to say this word.
-Oh.
-Yoga. Yoga.
You have to get --
And tell me when you're ready,
and I'm going to press the
button and then you do it.
You have to get --
-Oh!
-Alright, ready?
Here we go. Ready?
-Okay.
-Go.
-Um, meditative exercise
from the Far East.
-You have guided meditation.
Meditation of the day
for calm enabled.
Do you want to open it?
-Alexa, downward dog
is a form of...
-Sorry. I don't know that.
But I do have --
-Alexa...
-It's called "Bark Like a Dog."
Want to try it?
-Alright.
-No.
-I'm not going to give up.
-Go.
-What exercise rhymes with boga?
-Sorry. I'm not sure.
-Alright. Oh, ready?
What do you -- Alexa, what is
a low-impact exercise?
-This might answer
your question.
Low is from Duluth, Minnesota,
and it formed in Duluth,
Minnesota, United States.
-Alexa.
Alexa, Buddhist exercise.
-Exercise added to
your shopping list.
-Oh, I got it. Ready?
-Yeah.
-Alexa, exercise that
involves meditation.
-You have guided meditation.
Meditation of the day
for calm enabled.
Do you want to open it?
-No.
-Right.
Who is smarter than
the average bear?
Alexa --
-According to another
Amazon customer,
smarter than the average bear --
all it really means
is that the person being talked
about is smarter than average.
But you may be asking
where the bear came from.
That would be Yogi Bear,
a vintage cartoon character
from the 20th century.
Did that answer your question?
-Yes. That counts. That counts.
[ Both laugh ]
-That counts.
-Thanks for your feedback.
-Yeah, you're welcome for
the feedback.
Alright, let's do one more,
'cause...
[ Laughs ]
Dude, I love playing with you.
-Yeah.
-It's so fun.
-It's a great game.
It's a great game. Go on.
-Alright, here we go.
-Is that you first?
-Me first.
-You're going?
-Turtleneck.
-Hmm.
-Alright, ready?
Alexa, what shirt
would Steve Jobs wear?
-Here's something
I found on the web.
According to forbes.com,
Steve Jobs, on the other hand,
was known for his iconic
black long-sleeve
mock turtleneck and jeans.
-Yeah!
-Oh-ho!
-Whoo!
Even though it was a mock.
-No. Yeah, I was going for
a bit between
the turtle head
and the turtle body.
-Oh, okay. Oh.
[ Both laugh ]
Technically, that is correct.
Alright, here's yours, Ricky.
Can you make Alexa say "wagon"?
-Oh!
-Vehicle -- A stagecoach is an
example of this vehicle.
-A stagecoach is an example
of this vehicle.
-The Chevy convertible driven by
Pink is a random vehicle.
-Alright, ready for this?
-Yeah.
-♪ Like a wagon wheel ♪
♪ The wagon wheel ♪
-You can't do that, can you?
Because you're saying "wagon."
-I know. I won't say that.
I'm gonna say -- Alright, ready?
-Oh, yeah.
-Alright. Oh, gosh.
Who is the lead singer of
Hootie & the Blowfish?
-Hootie.
[ Both laugh ]
-What is his name?
It's Darius Rucker.
Alright, ready?
Alexa, what are
Darius Rucker's hits?
-Shuffling songs by
Darius Rucker on Amazon Music.
-No, can't you just
tell me them?
-What is a dog doing when it's
moving its tail back and forth?
-Hmm. I'm not sure.
-Alexa -- This is just
for fun now.
Alexa, a hen is a female bird.
What is a male bird called?
-This might answer
your question.
A male Aves is called a cock.
-Yes!
[ Both laugh ]
-It didn't say "wagon."
Dude, I'll give
you the win on that one.
I'll give you the win on that.
More with the one-and-only
Ricky Gervais
when we come back, everybody.
Not bad.
[ Both laugh ]
-Oh, great.
-Oh!